okay um let's start class we're
continuing the United States Iran War um
as I've said in in the previous class
the United States will invade Iran we
don't know when it might be two years
from now it might be six years from now
okay but eventually it will happen and
in today's class I want to go over some
of the reasons why the United States
will invade Iran and um I believe that
there'll be three major reasons okay
uh the first major reason is the United
States must defend its Empire second
major reason is that the United States
will be pressured by its allies mainly
Saudi Arabia and Israel into invading
Iran and the third reason is um the
Israel Lobby okay so in this in today's
class I want to explain to you what the
Israel Lobby is but first I need to I
need you to understand
what Christianity is okay so remember
that Christianity it's a religion about
a man Jesus who we know very little
about okay we think that he was born in
BCE and then he died in
31 uh
BC uh sorry CE Comm
era um we know that he is from a place
called Galilee we know know that the
Romans crucified him and that's about it
okay uh what his Believers say is that
he is God come to Earth and he was
preaching a gospel or a message that God
is returning the Kingdom of Heaven is
coming and after he was crucified he was
resurrected and then he went to heaven
and what's really important is that
Jesus with will eventually return okay
and this is called Second
Coming okay this is the second coming of
Jesus and when he comes he will bring
Heaven onto Earth and we will all live
forever in
peace okay so that's the story of Jesus
then the question then is why this
religion become so popular so popular in
fact that today about two billion people
believe in it okay it's the most popular
most power religion in the world and at
first the appeal of Christianity is that
it was a
revolutionary religion that promised a
better world to the world's
oppressed okay so if you look at the
early people who follow Christianity it
was slaves
peasants wom okay people who are
marginalized in
society and the idea of Jesus is that a
better world is coming where everyone
will be equal okay the meek shall
inherit the earth so if you think about
it Christianity uh is appealing because
what it is it's a free lottery ticket
does that make sense it's a lottery
ticket it cost you nothing and
hey if it's right then you go to
heaven okay so at first Christianity was
an extremely revolutionary religion and
its basic characteristics in the
beginning were uh it was
revolutionary it was
egalitarian um and it was anti Authority
and so these individuals who before were
out castmy okay like
criminals Jesus Promised hope salvation
and Redemption okay so before if you
were a criminal there was really no way
for you to redeem yourself in society
and Jesus is the promise of your
salvation and Redemption okay and that's
why it was so appealing to a lot of
people it became so popular that it
became the official religion of the
Roman
Empire now there's a problem okay
because remember Christianity is a
revolutionary egalitarian and anti-
Authority religion and now it's become
an
Empire so um they had they had to
develop new
theories to reinvent Christianity as a
establishment religion okay and and as
we discussed um last semester the person
who did this was
Augustine okay Augustine uh remember
that last semester we read city of God
and confessions and city of God and
confessions it's really to adopt
Christianity as an establish
establishment religion to reduce its
revolutionary nature okay so is this all
making sense to
you and one
problem that Austin had was the idea of
a second coming okay that the world will
end he had he had a major problem with
this idea for many reasons okay but the
first reason
is that you know if the world's going to
end why do we have to do anything why
can't we just drink and party and play
video games every day right what's the
point of working that's the first
problem right second problem is well
well why is Jesus coming back it's
because the world sucks right well who's
in charge of the world the Catholic
church is in charge of the world you
understand so Jesus is coming back to
destroy the authority of the Catholic
church that's not
good all right so for many reasons a
Austine basically said okay son coming
don't worry about it okay Jesus will
come back whenever he wants to come back
but before he comes back we the Catholic
Church will take care of everyone
okay all right so why is this important
this is important
because from Aug onwards we've had
Divergent understanding of what the
second coming means okay for people who
believe in the second coming the term we
use is pre
millennialism Prem Millennials
okay because the second coming promised
a thousand
years of
Peace okay premillennialism is this okay
pre means before right so when Jesus
comes back he will give us a thousand
years of peace and
prosperity okay do you
understand before he comes back okay
when he comes back he will give us a
thousand years of peace and
prosperity and what Augustine said is no
no no no that thousand years is just a
metaphor it's not actually going to
happen in fact it's already happened
because the Catholic church is giving us
this thousand years of peace and
prosperity okay so he's called a
millennial Millennial list which means
no okay that thousand years it's a man
of for it's not going to really happen
Okay so that's a second big idea now as
we know because all power became
concentrated in the Catholic Church
there's a rebellion
against the Catholic church called the
Reformation okay the
reformation and the idea of the
Reformation
is God did not mean
for his
authority to be established in the
church to be held by
priests God is meant to speak to all of
us through the
Bible okay so what the major difference
between the Catholic religion and the
Protestant religion is Catholics are not
allowed to read the Bible they don't
read the Bible whereas Protestants must
read the Bible they must seek meaning
and guiding
from their interpretation of the Bible
okay and because of the
Reformation you now have thousands tens
of thousands of different
religions spawning up okay does that
make sense all right so you have
different religions and you have
different
descent so let's look at England okay
England so England is a
king and the before the Catholic
church was supposed to have authority
over the king and of course the king did
not like
that so he supported the reformation and
he changed the Catholic church and call
the Anglican Church okay or the Church
of England which he would have authority
over but once the Reformation started
again you are now allowed to read the
Bible and because of that you have
thousands of new
religions coming up in England okay and
they believe different things but one
thing that they all believed in is the
Bible is the supreme
authority okay the the Bible is the
supreme authority not the king
right so this started a major conflict
between these groups and the king and
these people are called
denters and eventually this led to
something called the English Civil War
where the denters the pittin killed the
king okay and but but then the King was
reestablished and so this led to decades
and Decades of fighting in um England so
one way that um the king tried to
resolve this conflict is by setting all
these descenders to
America okay to America and the idea is
this these descenders believe that the
Bible is a supreme authority the Bible
asks us to do certain things okay
because it's written in the Bible for
example you're not allowed to drink
you're not allowed to dance you're not
allowed to have any fun you must focus
on your own spiritual
Improvement okay you're not allowed to
have slaves and so because they believe
these things they were constantly in
conflict with the establishment okay
with people in power and so the King was
like guys if you really believe in these
things go to America why because there's
nobody in America so you can build your
own kingdom of
heaven you understand okay so this is
the origin of the United States the
United States was founded as a Christian
Nation which put the Bible as the
supreme
authority okay does that make
sense you don't you you guys probably
don't know this about the United States
you think the United States it's a
non-religious secular
Multicultural nation that believes in
science right that's what it looks like
like like from the outside but inside
it's Soul it's history it is a Christian
Nation
dedicated to achieving the kingdom of
God on Earth okay and using the Bible as
the supreme authority and guide to
achieve this Kingdom on on Earth okay
does that make sense all
right
so um these people in America America
and these centers okay one question that
they always ask themselves is why isn't
Jesus back yet okay the second coming
what why isn't the second coming back
yet and different people have different
explanations okay and so from this group
come two more groups
okay um you have some people who call
the post millennial
okay and post millist believe that Jesus
will come back after we establish a
thousand years of the Christian church
in the world okay does that make sense
so we have to prove that we are
worthy of God God's not going to come
back and establish this for us we have
to do ourselves okay so these These are
people call Post which will say that
Jesus Jes come after the Thousand
Years but then you have another group
called
dispensationalist I I don't know how to
spell this word
actually okay anyway this dis is
historic okay all right so now the
premillennial are split into two other
groups so the historic premillennial are
people who believe believe what the
early Christians believed which is that
Jes Jesus is going to come back don't
worry when he's coming back just be a
good person and he'll come back
eventually okay it's not up to us to ask
when he's coming back he's God okay he
has a plan he knows what he's doing just
be patient guys okay that's the historic
premillennial and then you have another
group called the desp
desperation dispensation
list premillennial okay and what they
believe is something different they
believe that
oh in the Bible if you read the Bible
very very
closely it tells
you how and why Jesus will
return okay what the Bible says is
that there must be a nation called
Israel okay and Israel is
of
Jews and then Israel has something
called the
temple because that's
where God resides okay it must have the
temple and then what will happen
according to the Bible is
that the Antichrist okay or
Satan lives okay the then and then there
will be an antichrist okay Satan who
will be the Great Deceiver he'll pretend
to be God he'll pretend to be Messiah
but he's really Satan okay and then he
will launch a
war when they all the nations of the
world will try to attack Israel and at
this point Jesus will come back and he
will destroy the Antichrist he will save
Israel and he will Usher in a thousand
years of Peace before and then a
thousand years later you'll have the
last
judgment where God will judge us to be
either worthy or not worthy if we are
worthy we'll live on
forever if we're not worthy then we'll
burn in hell forever
okay okay so there are different
variations all this Prophecy with what
what what they believe okay so in other
words the historic historic
premillennial what they believe about
the coming of Jesus is it's a
promise okay Jesus promises to return
he's God he will keep his promise he's
probably very busy right now with other
things so don't worry about it guys okay
let's just be patient and Trust in in
Jesus okay that's what they
believe but the
dispensationalist premillennial believe
that the prophecy it's a
plan okay it's something that we must
achieve to bring Jesus back and we do
what the Bible's tells us to do which is
to say to have Israel as a nation run by
the Jews
to um have the temple and then to face
the Antichrist then Jesus will
return okay does that make
sense okay now so these are the four
different views of the end times okay
you have the historic
premar who believe that Jesus has promis
returned let's just wait guys don't
worry about it you have the
dispensationalist premillennialist
believe that we have to work hard to
bring Jesus back okay and then you have
the aist who are like now the thousand
years it's just a metaphor it's not
going to happen don't worry about it
guys okay and then you have the post
millennial who believe that it's up to
us to establish a good World Jesus is
not going to do it for us if we do this
then Jesus will return
okay
and so but remember guys
okay this is a very simple version of of
the four different beliefs even within
each belief there are variations okay
because again there are two billion
people who believe in Christianity and
they all believe something different
okay does that make sense all right are
we clear about the four
different um ideas any questions Okay so
okay okay so do you you don't actually
have to remember this okay but but but
all I'm trying to show you is that even
with in Christianity there's a debate
okay but there's a concern an obsession
as to when Jesus will return and how he
will return okay does that make sense
all
right
so
um this is important
now um most most
Christians don't believe in
dispensationalist premillennialism okay
in fact most Christians believe that
dispensationalist premillennialism is
actually pretty evil why why would it be
evil we shouldn't we should not we
cannot believe in dispensationalist
premillennialism because it's evil why
as a Christian why would you think this
is evil
what's a problem with believing that
there's a plan in the
Bible what why would that be
anti-christian okay so um this is hard
okay but but the idea is
that with this plan you're trying to
manipulate God it does that make sense
sense okay you're trying to force God to
return and you shouldn't do that if you
believe in God then you will trust God
and you will try your best to be a good
person which is what the Bible asks you
to
do and when God returns it's none of
your business okay it's not AR
concern so the dispensationalist
premillennial are an extremely
controversial minority within
Christianity okay
Christians most Christians don't
actually believe this and they find that
a lot of these beliefs to be
evil um and and and maybe even uh
Blasphemous okay you're insulting god
with this sort of thinking okay the
problem is that of all these groups the
dispensationalist millennial
premillennial are the most organized
and they're the most
fanatical they really believe that this
is true okay we know that throughout
history those who achieve their
objectives are people who tend to be the
most United and who are the most
fanatical in in a in achieving their
objective okay that's the first point
second point is that this sort
of
belief um thrives in a time of massive
uncertainty and inequality like the time
that we are living in today okay where
inequality is growing where there's more
instability and uncertainty so in other
words there are more and more people who
believe in dispensationalist
premillennialism okay does that make
sense
okay all right
so why this is
important is that
dispensationalist
premillennialist as Christians have done
a lot to cause conflict in the Middle
East okay so they're the ones who are
actually
encouraging conflict between the
Palestinians and the Israelis they're
the ones who want Israel and Iran to go
to war
why why are they actively encouraging
conflict between the Palestinians and
and and the Israelis why are they
encouraging a war between Iran and
Israel why would they want a war between
Iran and
Israel well no no well Israel is already
back
why because it's part of the prophecy do
you understand it's part of the prophecy
the prophecy is that Israel must be was
first must first be we Rec constitute it
as a nation okay this happened in
1948 and then Israel must go to war with
other
nations okay does that make sense so the
these Christians are actually
promoting war between Israel and its
neighbors okay does that make sense all
right okay so now the other thing is
that after the
Reformation okay um they developed a new
theology call Christian
Zionism Christian Zionism okay what is
Christian Zionism Christian Zionism is
the belief that as a Christian you must
support Jews in the return to
Israel okay so because remember that
um um Israel as a nation was only found
in
1948 and then um
basically it um in about
70 BCE the
Romans burned down the temple okay so
for
about almost 2,000 years
really the Jewish people have not lived
in so sorry sorry the Jews were not in
control of Israel okay about 2,000 years
and there are Christians who believe
that it is our responsibility is our
duty to help Jews take control over
Israel okay and they believe this for
many different reasons so Christian
Zionist some may believe that that's
what the Bible
says God promised Israel to the Jews
okay so Christian Zionism
intersects with dispensationalist
prism okay there are Christian Zionist
who believe that okay for Jesus to
return we also we need Israel back and
we need Israel to be in conflict with
the Middle East
okay so in other words
okay yeah all of them all of them okay
so um so Christian
Zionism um I mean you can make me
argument that it's a pretty evil idea
why because they're using the Jewish
people as a tool as a mechanism in order
to achieve what they believe which is
the return of
Jesus okay does that make sense because
um Christianity believes that if Jesus
returns then all Jews then then then je
then Judaism as a religion will cease to
exist 2third of all Jews will die in the
battle and the and the rest a third will
will immediately convert to
Christianity okay so you can make the
argument that Christian Zionism it's a
pretty
cynical um and a pretty evil
idea
okay and then from Christian Zionism we
have the idea of
Zionism okay and Zionism is the belief
among certain
Jews that two things okay one is that
the Jews are the chosen people of God
and that Israel is a promised land and
therefore
Jews must return to Israel okay does
that make sense okay but what's
important is before Christian Zionism
came
along Zionism was not Jews didn't really
think this okay so it's it was the
Christians who supported this idea of
Zionism and even when this idea came
about which which was about 200 years
ago it was an extremely
unpopular religion very extremely
unpopular idea the reason why is
Jews didn't think they were a race of
people they felt they were a
religion okay they felt that okay um I'm
in I'm in Iraq well guess what I'm an
Iraqi like everyone else I may have a
different belief but I'm still Iraqi
okay they didn't put the religion above
their nationality or their uh race okay
do you understand and Zionism is like no
being a Jewish person is a race and
therefore you must return to
Israel okay the problem uh with with all
this is that in Israel uh Palestine it
was mainly Arab people okay so there are
very few Jewish people and in fact
Zionism couldn't convince anyone to come
to um Palestine okay but then of course
the Holocaust
happened and after the Holocaust many
Jews start to go to Israel and in 1948
they established the state of um Israel
okay and the Christian
Zionist and the
dispensationalist premillennialist were
we're very happy with the establishment
of Israel because they feel that we've
achieved the first step in this plan to
bring Jesus back
okay okay does that make sense okay
um so um to summarize the main message
is this okay here's what you need to
know first is that Christ there are many
Christians who believe that Israel and
the Jews must be used as a tool to bring
Jesus back okay that's the first thing
second thing is that America was founded
as a Christian Nation therefore its soul
is
Christian its first leaders
were uh Christians who believed in
Christian
Zionism their descendants now control
the military and the foreign policy
operatus of America okay the second
thing
okay and the third thing is that uh
Israel as a na as a
nation
um thinks that it can use chrisan
Zionism in order to advance its GE
geopolitical interest which is to
basically um gain control over the
Middle
East okay do you understand and that's
what's driving the conflict
between Israel and
Iran does that make
sense okay what's driving the conflict
between Israel and Iran is America
believes it has a religious
responsibility to protect Israel against
Iran in fact if there's a war between
Iran in Israel that's a good thing
because it's going to
drive this prophecy and the return of
Jesus
okay and then the and people in Israel
are like you know what if we go to war
with Iran America is going to fight for
us so why
not right we don't have to fight this
war America is going to do it for us so
why not fight this war we lose nothing
we gain everything from this
war okay so um the idea is that all this
is driven by a religious world view
understanding the
world okay and over
time this worldview will only become
more
popular in
America okay does that make sense right
okay okay good any questions about
this do anything that's not that's not
clear about what I just what what what
what I
just
explained do you mean to clarify
anything
okay
um U I don't really understand the
question can you can you repeat the
question
right so okay so both Judaism and
Christianity are religions okay there's
no race there's no race to the idea of
Christianity right you can be Chinese
and Christian you can be American and
Christian it doesn't
matter right and that's what the Jewish
people say as well I can be Chinese and
Jewish I can be American and Jewish
because Jew being being Jewish is a
religion but the idea of
Zionism is that being Jewish person is a
race in fact you are directly
descended from the Hebrews in the Bible
which is complete nonsense this is not
true
okay um
so um
Zionism is the main political belief of
Israel right
why does is Israel exist because Israel
is the promised land that God gave to
his chosen people okay and this was a
promise that dates back at least 3,000
years to the time of Abraham and it's
written in the Bible therefore it must
be true okay does that make
sense all right any other
questions okay that's a great question
okay all right so I'm making AR
that Christian
Zionism and dispensationalist prism will
over time become more popular religions
in America okay and the question and
Charles asked like well why okay let's
go back to the founding of Christianity
why did Christianity become so popular
it became popular um because it was in
the Roman Empire okay at that time there
something called the
Pax Roma which meant the Roman
peace okay which meant that the Romans
controlled everything therefore there
were no Wars therefore people were at
peace right and you think that's a good
thing right the problem is that if
there's peace then you have massive
inequality okay because war is a
mechanism back then of social Mobility
right War killed people and if War kills
people that creates opportunities for
the people who are alive but if there's
no war then what happens is if I'm a
rich person guess what guys I become
more Rich if you're poor what happens
you become more poor okay so as a poor
person what do you think you think that
life is hopeless life is pointless
there's no future there's no hope right
and so Jesus comes along and says listen
if you believe in me then I will bring
the Kingdom of Heaven onto Earth and I
will is I will destroy inequality
everyone will be the same okay so again
back then it was a free lottery ticket
today we live in something called the
Pax
Americana and the Pax Americana same
thing where for the past 70 years
there's been peace around the world
right very few people have
died but all that means really is is
that inequality has increased fewer and
fewer people have money okay guys
billionaires make no sense do you
understand why should a few people have
all the money that makes no sense
because money is meant as a mechanism of
exchange and transaction right you you
use money you should spend your money if
it's all in the bank what's the point of
that okay
so having billionaires is a bad
thing and if you go to America you'll
find that there are many young people
who feel that like life is
pointless okay so they're looking for
Alternatives you understand and this
idea of dispensationalist prism which is
like what's happening right now in
Israel will lead to a better world
that's kind of attractive to you you
understand
right well because you're poor and
you're stuck being poor guys imagine you
are um a delivery person in China in
Beijing okay you're like a qu right what
hope do you have for the
future you have your life is pointless
and and hopeless no one's going to marry
you even if someone marries you you
can't have children because you can't
afford to have your children go to
school you can't buy a house you can't
afford
anything you're stuck being a delivered
person for the rest of your
life do you understand do you do you
know do you know how many deliv first
people there are in China millions and
millions okay you have millions and
millions of young men
have who have no hope in the
future
right yes because Jesus is coming and
he's going to destroy the world we live
in that's exactly right Christianity is
a free Lottery it cost you nothing and
if you win you win big okay
right what does it cost you it cost you
nothing right okay do you understand
that's why it will become more popular
over
time excuse
me right so what you do is you
support America you support Israel you
you support the war against Iran you
want you want more conflict in the
Middle East because the conflict in the
Middle East will drive the prophecy
right do you
understand that's what you want you want
more
war what what what good does peace do
you
right peace just means like at like
tomorrow you'll still be poor and
hopeless right but War it's an
opportunity for a new
world exactly right so all this
inequality is making people much more
extreme and
desperate right which will leave which
will lead people more people to believe
in dispensationalist
premillennialism
okay um the government of course does
not want any
instability but what can the government
do about
it
I you're absolutely right okay so the
government could provide social
welfare uh to poor people but where will
the money come from
right you
understand
okay okay who's more dangerous to you a
few rich people or millions of poor
people
no no no no no no a few rich people are
much more D more dangerous than millions
of poor people do you
understand that's right United right
poor people don't know how to
unite that's
right um yeah but but but they don't
um right
okay okay so doesn't make sense okay all
right so this is this is the so I mean
it's hard because this is religion okay
and we're not religious I'm not
religious you're not religious so we
don't we understand how religious people
think okay but remember that on this
planet on Earth most people are
religious and they take their religion
very very seriously okay you understand
they're willing to die for the religion
because they think that if I die from
from a religion I'll go to
heaven excuse
me okay all right so
so that's exactly right do you
understand okay right because you're not
giving people any hope and religion
gives people hope
listen in the real world the poor will
always lose the rich will always win no
matter what happens the poor doesn't
realize that's right that's why they're
poor okay